[Music]
do
hello welcome to the table my name is
mariah if you're new here welcome we're
really excited that you're here if
you're not new here we're all so excited
that you're here
if you're joining us online we're
excited that you're here too thank you
for tuning in
and we just have the one announcement
and if you've been here for a couple
weeks it's the same one
next week we are going to be doing trunk
or treat at 5 00 pm here at the table
and we will have food and drinks
provided and we still have room if you
want to
open up your trunk and make a couple
cute decorations and bring some candy
you can still sign up for that right in
the back awesome
i'm going to go ahead and pray for us
and then we'll get started
lord thank you so much for tonight thank
you for us all being here i'm so excited
for this weather it's been amazing
please help us to have a wonderful
service thank you for our amazing
worship team i pray that you'll lead
them with your holy spirit
thank you god for this time we love you
so much amen
amen
thanks girl
well we are going to get started so if
you guys want to stand with us if you
are comfortable doing so
and
just join in as
as you feel um comfortable i love just
giving a quick little intro that worship
is a whole body experience and it's a
whole community experience it's not
about the people on the stage just
singing their songs but it's about each
one of us entering in from whatever
place you came in tonight and if it's
just singing along that's great if it's
just engaging the words and listening to
them and letting them soak in and
agreeing with what feels true to you
then that's wonderful if it's using your
body to clap or raise your hands
or
stomp your feet please do so this is an
open space and each one of you are
invited into this it is something that
we want to engage as a community um
where we get to kind of speak out what
we believe to be true about god and the
way that he loves us and the way he
engages us so please join in all right
um
gary's gonna get us started
so
let's do this
[Music]
my life is yours
my hope is
[Music]
because you've made this sinner
holy
and
[Music]
your glory is so
of my life is to worship in your life
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
my life is yours my life is
my
[Music]
oh
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
and the heartbeat of my life
is to worship in your life
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
glory glory
hallelujah
jesus
[Music]
glory
hallelujah
jesus
[Music]
glory glory
[Applause]
[Music]
away my sins
is
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing but
[Music]
[Applause]
glory
hallelujah
[Music]
let's sing that to him glory
glory
hallelujah
[Music]
glory
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah yes
we're going to move into our prayers of
the people so if this is your first time
with us this is um a tradition that's
been passed down in christian history
and the way it will go is that i'll
begin with a short prayer and then i
will open it up to any of you who would
like to speak out a name of someone
that you would like us to hold up in
prayer before god or maybe a situation
that's been weighing on your heart
and we ask that you just share their
name it doesn't need to be their story
we want to respect their privacy but we
do want to take advantage of the
opportunity when we come together to
shoulder each other's burdens and to
lift people before god believing that he
is here he's with us he cares he's a
part of our lives and our stories
and um we want to remember those you
know who
who need help who are who we're carrying
um together make room for that
so uh join in and when you see words on
the screen in red then those are words
that we can all pray out together and i
believe karen is going to be oh nope
sorry but we are watching um for your
online comments so if you're joining us
online and want to share a prayer
request there then mariah will read
those out to us so that we can all be a
part of this experience together
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them god
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan for the
injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names and situations up to you
[Music]
mandy
harper
from online nancy's chemo and upcoming
ct scan pray for healing
teachers and educators for health to all
those that are battling with kovid
[Music]
mary
grace
kirsten
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you god that you
will fill them with life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
[Music]
to see things like you do
oh god i look to you
you're where my health comes from
give me wisdom
to know just what to do
yes
[Music]
oh god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
[Music]
to see
oh things
i look to you
you where my help comes from
[Music]
give me wisdom
to see things like you do
i will love you
lord my strength
[Music]
forever all my days
oh god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
[Music]
to see things like you do
oh god i look to you
you're where my help comes from
[Music]
give me wisdom
to know just what to
[Music]
i will love you
lord my
shield
[Music]
oh i will love you
forever all my days
hallelujah
[Music]
we can trust him hallelujah
hallelujah our god reigns
forever all my days hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
yeah let's give that a hand
god we praise you we give you our
hallelujahs and we trust god we trust
our friends our family our lives
we trust you with them god
thank you jesus
[Music]
psalm 3
lord how many are my foes
how many rise up against me
many are saying of me god won't deliver
him
but you lord
are a shield around me
my glory
the one who lifts my head high
i call out to the lord and he answers me
from his holy mountain
i lie down and sleep
i wake again
because the lord sustains me
[Music]
i will not fear though ten thousands
assail me on every side
arise lord deliver me my god strike all
my enemies
from the lord comes deliverance
may your blessing be on your people
me out upon the waters
[Music]
the great unknown
where feet may fit
and there i find you in the mystery
in oceans deep
my faith will stand
so i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes
[Music]
when above rise my soul will rest in
your
embrace for i
am
yours
and you are
[Music]
[Applause]
your grace abounds and deepest waters
your sovereign hand
will be my
[Music]
where guide may fail and fear surrounds
me
you never
fail
and you won't start now
[Music]
when oceans rise my soul will rest in
your
embrace for i
am yours
[Music]
you are my
trust is without borders
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
and take me deeper than my feet
and my faith will be made stronger in
the presence of my savior
spirit lead me where my trust is without
borders let me walk upon the
[Music]
could waters wander
my faith would be made stronger in the
presence of my savior
let me walk upon the waters
wherever you
would take me
[Music]
my faith would be made stronger in the
presence
jesus
[Music]
so i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the
waves and oceans rise my soul will rest
in your embrace
for i
am
[Music]
god i do ask that you would give us
the boldness
and the courage to follow you wherever
you're calling us
wherever you lead god
wherever you put your hand i pray god
that we would go
[Music]
that we would be ready to listen and
follow your lead
[Music]
god would we find you in the places
where we least expect it would we find
you calling us to yourself
would we take you with us into the
places that you're not invited
god and sometimes admitting that even
those are places in my own heart
or i've built up a wall or where i'm
afraid
where i want to handle it in my own
strength
places where shame has taken root
places where discouragement has taken
over god
in those places we ask that we would
find you this week
shining light in the darkness
that we would feel hope seeping into our
bones
that we would feel your goodness
saturating our lives
we would find you in the people
that we've disregarded
jesus help us to see you in all things
and take you into every space
[Music]
we love you
and we trust you god even where it's
scary and unknown god we trust you we
put our faith in you god
give us the faith that we need
to get through each day
to live as believers
of jesus
the way
the love
and the light
amen
thank you guys so much for joining us in
worship why don't you guys take a second
just to turn to the people around you
say hello
um and brett's gonna get going on our
message
all right well good evening everyone
grace and peace
welcome welcome welcome it's uh a joy to
have all of you here and that of course
includes those joining us online we are
so glad to have you with us and uh and
everyone who's new and kind of settling
in and you know making their way into a
new place and that can take a lot of
courage to come through those doors so
uh thank you at some point we were all
new here so we know what it's like um
yeah so it's a joy to have you with us
so we are in uh this is part two
in our our new series uh titled first
peter where we are of course uh simply
walking through the book of first peter
um and we're our goal is to kind of try
to make it through chapter one by uh the
time advent hits so right about
thanksgiving um and then we'll kind of
hit the pause button for christmas
advent season and then we'll pick uh
pick back up later so um yeah so it
should be pretty um thorough at the very
end of this series boy i hope you
understand first peter if not
i have failed that's not just me where
we're at because we are going quite so i
mean last week we covered verses one and
two
uh this week uh we'll be in verses uh
three through nine so i mean you can
tell we're not exactly like flying
through this thing you know we're not
doing a chapter a week or anything so
anyway hopefully hopefully it sinks in
and connects um so the title of the
specific message tonight is why faith
why faith you could kind of hear in a
lot of our songs the the themes of
stepping out in the waters and the um
the image it's an image of god's feel a
shield um that kind of acts as like a
shield of faith which we'll come to in
the message later um
so hopefully you're kind of already
picking up on the on the theme tonight
um so i want to start by reading
verses three we'll just read three
through five at the very end of the
message i'll kind of cover six through
nine um and we'll kind of incorporate
that in
so starting in verse three of first
peter praise be to the god and father of
our lord jesus christ in his great mercy
he has given us new birth into a living
hope through the resurrection of jesus
christ from the dead and into an
inheritance that can never perish spoil
or fade this inheritance is kept in
heaven for you who through faith are
shielded by god's power can you hear it
you see the image shielded by god's
power
until the coming of the salvation that
is ready to be revealed in the last time
so um anytime we start talking about
faith people
there's i think a lot of
misunderstandings around this this term
and so i want to to start by sharing um
this is a little excerpt from the
wonderful book alice in wonderland
um most of you probably have more seen
the movie
you know i don't know how many people
are like reading lewis carroll's
original works you know probably not but
um
right this is a portion from that
well i can't believe it said alice or i
can't believe that
well can't you
the queen said in a pitying tone well
try again
draw a long breath
and shut your eyes
alice laughed well there's no use trying
she said
one can't believe in possible things
well i dare say you haven't had much
practice said the queen when i was
younger i always did it for half an hour
a day why sometimes i've believed as
many as six impossible things before
breakfast
uh this is what i think often people
think of faith as it's like oh so
basically when something's not at all
true but you just really want it to be
so then you you bring it you play the
faith card
right it's sort of it's believing the
six impossible things um and this is
just not the case um i think instead
what faith is well because really i mean
if you kind of live long enough you
start to realize that at the kind of at
the end of the day there's actually a
lot of things that take faith um in
other words you can have reasons for
something
um but you can't put everything in test
tube
you know and in fact a lot of the things
that like matter most in the world
can't be put in a test tube and just
experimented on to where you're like ah
fact i just know it like our whole kind
of deconstruction series that we did
last time or you know a few a month or
so ago now um and that went for a while
was a few months like that was touching
on a lot of topics a lot of things like
all the most important things that
honestly like that society just assumes
and runs by and if those things went
away it would be a
disaster i mean i'm talking about for
example goodness
you know i mean even something as
fundamental as that like hey there's
good and then there's bad
well guess what there's like a whole lot
of faith in that concept now you can
have reasons for it but there's no like
knock down argument that's just like the
proof where everyone you know reads that
art that article or something and it's
like oh now i believe yep no faith
required i mean there's a certain
element of faith operating even
something like goodness um what else i
wrote a few things down there's of
course the presence of god um even the
idea of beauty
um the idea of truth um
there's just all sorts of things that
there's a there's you can have reasons
for them but at the end of the day
there's no like knock down argument this
will convince everyone you know if you
were just a logical person you would
believe you know it's like no
so much of what matters in life doesn't
play out like that there is an element
of faith uh and so i think it's not to
the detriment of christian i don't think
it's like oh yeah religion how annoying
um no no i think it's actually a
strength of christianity that it's just
very upfront and honest about this like
look there is an element of faith
that's true and there's certain things
that just can't be experienced until you
start to step into them
and it sort of takes that certain even
it's cliche but true right a certain
step of faith and then you step out and
then you're like oh now i see kind of
what they're talking about you know
um
yeah there's there's some i think
there's something to this this idea and
you might say that it's not that it like
it's not irrational this is the problem
with like the queen this quote you know
i just can't believe impossible things
you know well just go ahead and try is
like that's sort of faith as as
irrationalism as you know rejection of
the rational instead of trans
trans-rational like it transcends but
includes the rational right it doesn't
reject it but it takes it sort of yes
there are reasons for certain things
right and that's important and have
reasons for why you believe you know
everything from god to
trusting you know the resurrection or
what i think it's good to have reasons
but there's no like knock down here you
go if you just you know see the logic um
so it includes the reasons it includes
the rational thinking part of us i don't
like when church becomes the place where
we check our brains at the door it's not
a virtue right so it includes that and
yet it does transcend it and go beyond
it and it does christian faith christ
does ask us to take some steps into the
unknown to step out on the waters as we
sing like that is for sure
a huge um
part of this
so i think in the end you might say that
a good word for faith is trust
trust
i think that's a lot of what's happening
in that word of faith it's it's about
okay god
i'm gonna trust that you are
i'm gonna trust that you are as good as
jesus revealed you to be i'm going to
trust um that the scriptures in all of
their messiness and beauty somehow point
to the truth
of who christ is
and and i'm gonna trust god that that i
can go through life like this
rather than like this
right and this is this is where i think
faith matters
because um as we'll get into a little
bit suffering hits us and it's real easy
to get real bitter
quick
right you kind of start off as a child
and it's like yeah the world's beautiful
you know every child or hopefully unless
there's been like serious abuse you know
they go there they're open-handed right
they're like yes the world you know
and but what happens life just smacks us
and all of a sudden we're like oh my
gosh this is the world this is life
and it's real easy to get real like
rigid which is kind of my big idea for
tonight if you're a notetaker you can
jot this down
the word faith is not about believing
six impossible things before breakfast
instead christian faith is an
orientation
of trust towards the god we've come to
know in jesus
this trust allows us to remain gentle
and relaxed throughout our life rather
than angry and rigid can you hear it
like this i think this like really
matters for people um and towards the
end of the message actually we'll have
some stories of folks
who i think this
really matters
faith really matters
um
yeah it impacts us spiritually our souls
our psychological state our emotional
state
um
yeah it matters so i want to kind of
unpack this through this passage so
let's start with um verse 3 again where
peter writes praise be to the god and
father of our lord jesus christ
in his great mercy he has given us new
birth
new birth into a living hope through the
resurrection of jesus christ from the
dead
let's start with that language of new
birth there's a lot of echoes here from
our message last week if you were here
if you listened later online um you know
we talked about verse one he taught he
refers to this church that he's writing
to as um as exiles in other words the
sort of strangers and aliens in their
own land which of course they weren't
literally but he's saying this is what
it means to be a christian is to be sort
of a stranger so we
it's a stranger to your culture in a
sense so we said we kind of have this
phrase as strangers and seeds right
strangers to the surrounding culture in
a way um seeds of kingdom culture this
is kind of what god calls us to um
so
now by by strangers hopefully it's not
just we get real weird you know be
strange for the sake of being strange
like no hopefully hopefully it's weird
in a good way in other words as we
apprentice ourselves to christ as we
start to live his cruciform would be the
theological term kind of the the way of
the cross
as we learn to live into that that way
of enemy love
and forgiving 70 times seven
grace justice seeking compassion as we
live into that um the the idea is is
basically that um
we start to well at times it goes really
beautifully and people are like that's
the most awesome thing in the world and
other times not so much
right other times people hurt us for and
then that's where the suffering can come
so the idea is basically as we live in
that way we become weird hopefully in a
good way
to our culture
and um
and
you might even say that um well let me
actually connect it to verse three so
this is where i think the language of
new birth is a nod back to verse one
because he says you've been given this
um i see praise begotten father
who has given us a new birth into a
living hope so the new birth i think
this is a metaphor um you've even heard
it in the culture you know born again
it's kind of become this terribly
painful cliche in the in the church
which i hope we can kind of recover and
not just hear it as like oh weird you
know but here it has the beautiful
metaphor that it is like if you think of
it a birth right it brings you into the
world into a particular family into a
particular region and culture a place
right and as we touched on last week and
there's beauty in that there's a lot of
good you pick up like god's presence his
preserving presence is there in that
culture doing good things and there's a
lot of
not good right and this is where
peter picks up on this image of a new
birth he's given us a new birth right
some of us really need that especially
we came up from like a super messed up
family
right it's like yeah i could use a new
birth you know it's
of course it's not literal but it's it's
this kind of inward psychological
emotional spiritual this just entire
transformation that makes us in a sense
not not um in a good way a little bit
distant from the culture right in a good
way not in a i'm rejecting my family or
i'm turning my back on you all you're
terrible you know but in a um you almost
have to be a little bit weird and be a
little bit distant to be able to be
helpful
does that kind of make sense have you
ever found that in your family like to
be helpful sometimes you have to kind of
break a few of the chains that maybe
held that family culture down or that
region if you grew up in texas there's
lots of good in texas and some not so
good right and so you've got to kind of
get a little bit distant a little bit
weird so that you can be a helpful
healing presence that's kind of the
image of um of new birth
all right but that's not all he says
this new birth does what well in his
great mercy he's given us a new birth
into a living hope
a living hope through the resurrection
of jesus christ from the dead um
again all right what is this language of
a living hope i think it's kind of
referring to two things um one is kind
of an escape from what we might call the
the kind of meaninglessness of the cycle
of sin
um one way i think of sin is often as
bad solutions to very real problems
you know um kind of coping mechanisms
and instead of you know choosing like
healthy life-giving sort of um ways that
look like jesus to you know hope cope
and heal from life uh we choose like you
know
dumb stuff that we know it's like even
in the moment we know like this is
unhealthy this is dumb you know i mean
it's sort of like you
for example you have a breakup and what
do you do you like jump into the next
relationship and you know it's like this
is not smart i know it's dumb i know but
i'm just hurting and so and then so all
of a sudden now you're in this
relationship with this person they kind
of are getting weird vibes you have
weird vibes now you're hurting them
right this is what the bible calls sin
that this it's not just like you did bad
but it's like it's these unhealthy ways
of coping and so i think this living
hope what it does is it sort of calls us
beyond that
right out of our cycles of sin out of
our cycles even just addiction that's
addictions are you know
bad solutions to very real problems
um
so there's there's something beautiful
about being kind of called out of that i
think of the book of ecclesiastes for
example that opens with these words
meaningless meaningless utterly
meaningless everything is meaningless
um that's sort of the cycle of sin right
and this is where kind of secular
culture is honestly being sort of
swallowed up by this right now
um it's a huge problem so that's so we
have a living hope so that's the first
thing um kind of called out of the mean
list of meaninglessness of sin i think
second though it's also about pushing
back on the hopelessness of death right
he said a living hope
in the face of resurrection or through
the resurrection of jesus christ by the
way i see a few of you fanning
yourselves sorry the ac broke
if you're joining us online tonight
you're the lucky ones gotcha
you got your air conditioning
a little at least i'm it's bad i'm a
forehead sweater this could be a problem
in a minute i don't know we'll see this
is like i'll be like sweating nowhere
else and all of a sudden my fault
so anyway we'll see all right back to
living hope all right so um i think this
is about pushing back on the
hopelessness of death right you think of
jesus resurrection it's a hope why
because it's super sad to think about
the fact that you and everyone you hold
dear will die
and then it's like the lights just go
out like
just that's it
that's like that's
pain that's painful
um i recently went to uh to a funeral
for my my aunt in san antonio about two
weeks ago
and um
she was she was a she's a wonderful
woman she had one of those smiles that
like lit up the room you know and the
laugh like the not subtle laugh you know
just i mean um just huge smile just she
was a really
a beautiful man a warm presence in my
life um
and so we we traveled down there i was
going to be with my uncle
um you know that was of course his wife
and then my two cousins shelly and cara
who i was close to my family is kind of
scattered all over the united states
uh so i didn't grow up like with a lot
of you know local extended family and so
even though they were in san antonio
though so like a little bit close you
know only five hours so holidays and
certain times we'd see them so i was
close to them
um so we traveled down there a few weeks
ago
uh for for her funeral and
um i was sitting there in the service
and of course was at a church she was a
believer she was she
loved jesus very much served at the
church and all the things so it was very
much a christian funeral and it struck
me like the just the whole atmosphere
there
it was really interesting i was
contrasting it with where i was about 15
years ago those of you who know my story
i was kind of flirting with atheism
about 15 years ago and i remember going
to funerals around that time and i found
them just the most depressing things in
the world i mean just kind of like the
worst
and i think at least a big piece of it
was because of that sense of of
hopelessness
right it's just like the lights go out
and that's it and there and there was
something so
so beautiful as i could kind of step
back a little bit and and see my uncle
and cousins and to see how of course i
mean were they grieving absolutely
um were they in utter despair
no
why not i think they have a faith it has
led them to a living hope
right and they trust that it's goodbye
but it's just goodbye for now right for
from god we have come
and to god we will all return
through christ by grace right cross and
resurrection like and when we trust that
what god has done for jesus he will one
day do for all people
right and so that's where the christian
faith it's a it's a profoundly um
hopeful vision
of life
and that matters like that changes us
you know it changes even how we
experience funerals
so that's the two things i think a
living hope what does that mean i think
it's about the kind of pushing back on
the hopelessness the meaninglessness of
cycles of sin and the hopelessness of of
death
so um let me keep moving verse three uh
for a little context but i want to get
into verses four and five in his great
mercy he's given us new birth into a
living hope through the resurrection of
jesus christ from the dead verse four
and into an inheritance that can never
perish spoil or fade this inheritance is
kept in heaven for you
uh my guess is that inheritance you know
it's through the life death and
resurrection of jesus as i said from god
we've come to god we return and so
that's that's i think what he's nodding
to um is is that idea that that kind of
eternity of living in the glorious
beautiful presence of god verse 5 which
is where i really want to spend some
time you who through faith
you are shielded by god's power until
the coming of the salvation that is
ready to be revealed in the last
time
you who through faith are shielded by
god's power i think that's such an
interesting
kind of image of
faith as a as a sort of shield
um almost this you know what does a
shield do it's protective right it's not
like offensive like attack with a shield
that'd be kind of weird instead it's a
it's a defensive thing right and that's
that kind of got me to thinking about
which is the definition i open with
right faith as this trust
in christ
that protects
that protects our gentleness that
protects um that kind of open-hearted
posture towards the world that as we get
older man it's just easy to lose
too much suffering
right it's just easy to lose i think
it's a little bit cheesy but i've been
um my brother-in-law josh he's been
taking me through the whole marvel
series
like the whole thing
wow um
it's a lot i didn't quite know what i
was signing up for it's like oh my gosh
how many like side stories are there you
know so many um but a lot of them are
quite well done and there's uh i think
of it's again it's a little bit cheesy
but i'm thinking of captain america with
his awesome shoot i'm like does that
shield ever break what's the what is the
deal you know he throws it bangs it on
the ground all the things you know and
that's sort of the image i'm getting
again a little cheesy but i'm getting
that kind of a picture of faith of this
thing that it just doesn't matter like
it no matter what we're facing it just
withstands it just keeps going um now
having said this i i should clarify that
peter is very clear what this does not
mean
um in fact he spends most if you know
the book of first peter like the whole
context is suffering right so just to be
clear what this is not saying and what
i'm not preaching tonight is if you have
faith and if you've got that shield you
know well then nothing bad will ever
happen to you
no worries it's just gonna you know to
be a christian is to have no problems um
just to be clear no
that is not at all what i'm saying i
hear some connection yeah everyone we
know this right um in fact quite the
opposite kind of coming back to the
point i made earlier when you live in
this cruciform way jesus when you the
way the cross again sometimes it's
beautiful and genius and it's like yeah
people just love you for it and
sometimes not so much you know
and like suffering can come as a result
of this
so so what he's saying is you who
through faith you're shielded by god's
power um
it's again it's not about believing in
six impossible things
but instead it's this orientation of
trust it's this openness christian faith
and orientation of trust towards the god
we've come to know in jesus a trust that
allows us to remain gentle and relaxed
throughout our life rather than angry
and rigid and you know sometimes it's
not until you suffer
that you find out
how
how strong that shield is so to speak
how um how deep that faith goes
you know
um
so i want to share towards the end of
the message tonight i want to share a
few um a few stories
one i'm going to share on behalf of the
person and i did get their permission to
share and the other will be kind of
interview style
so i want to talk first about vicki
ferris how many of you have met vicki
ferriss a few i see a few hands vicky is
the lady she always sits right over here
my left your right she has the wonderful
hair tonight it's blue i think i've seen
different colors it's gone maybe has it
been green or purple
yeah someone she's just naughty maybe
that just means yes all the above um
vicky
vicky is wonderful um
and um i did i got her permission to
share some of her story because i've
known vicky for many years now she knew
me when i was like little little guy we
went to the same church way back in the
day um and then we kind of had lost
touch for a long time but uh so a few
months back i went to her uh apartment
heard more of her story kind of catching
up on our miss you know missing 25 years
or whatever
and um
you know vicky she's a very special lady
she has but she suffered
she suffered she um right now she has
parkinson's disease
thus the walker that you see her come in
with it's also why she's kind of here
you know like here twice and maybe not
here on a sunday
because you know the way she described
it she has some good days and then she
has some bad days and then she has some
terrible days
and she just you know she can't be here
um but when i was chatting with her she
was sharing about how just um so she
lives alone
um with her dog little brother that's
his name i thought for sure it was a
nickname nope that is his literal name
little brother get over here
um so cute and so she but she lives
alone you know
and um it was a while over a decade ago
her uh her son drew he passed away
tragically then just a few years ago her
ex-husband who she was still very close
to his name was wally he passed away
so
uh she has one daughter who's still kind
of local but that's it and so i was
talking with her in her apartment just
like what's your experience like like
cause i'm kind of seeing her you know
little one-bedroom apartments over there
by wiley high school she mentioned we
have a few people mariah is one i see
the piers men's here they rotate picking
her up to get her to church
that's you guys are awesome that's yeah
give him a hand that's beautiful
um
so i'm in her apartment and i'm seeing
it you know and i'm thinking like wow
this is like her place like spends a lot
of time here
and
she said you know bruh it hasn't been
just until the last few years
that like living alone
experiencing no parkinson's
um kind of getting worse at times that
it's it has forced me it has pushed me
deeper and closer to god than i have
ever been
and she said sometimes
i'm sitting
there in my apartment she said and it
just the thought kind of comes to me
like
what is this
like here i am
i'm sick
i'm alone
like what
what is my life
he said but then the thought it just
comes to me
wait a minute
i
am never
alone
i'm never alone
god is with me
and she said that thought encourages me
so much she says i i've never spent a
day alone in my life
and you know now what is that
right that for her that's not some airy
fairy concept
right like for her this matters that's
called faith
trust
an orientation of trust that has helps
to keep her gentle
open to life open to you all open to god
instead of rigid and fighting and bitter
and why me and just keeps open
right
vicky we love you we're so so glad that
you're here and a part of our community
so so glad
all right for our last story i want to
um bring up a dear friend some of you
may know her it's been a while nikki
parker
uh so let's grab these chairs thank you
yeah give her a hand give her hand as
she comes up
yeah maybe just right here
here you go friend
six
yeah that's fine
nikki oh my gosh it's so good to see you
okay so great to be here a little
background uh so and nikki she'll share
more of her story in a minute but um
nikki she's helped to start this
community but she hasn't been here in
like a year and a half
um it's two years it's been yeah it's
been a long time uh just with coven all
the things so um so we're really really
glad to to have her so um nikki
obviously you have like been
you have been through it not just last
two years but for a long time so can you
kind of bring for those who don't know
your story kind of bring us into the
loop like what have you been through
what's up
um
i had a implant hip implant in 2013 and
it failed no in 2009 and it failed and
so um i've had a lot of complications
ever since then because of the failure
and
in the last three and a half years has
been the most problems and i've had 23
surgeries in the last three and a half
years
sometimes staying in the hospital for
days sometimes just day surgery but
always going home
suffering and
pain
and my family's gone through it as well
they've heard
me cry they've heard me moan they've
heard a lot of stuff especially this
last year
this last year was the worst of all
because usually i can like just bounce
back and
fake it till you make it kind of thing
and you know i would bounce back and
fake it till i made it but this time
i've been on bed rest for almost a year
now
i'm allowed to be here they said i can
start
walking
so i've been on bed rest this year and
on top of that it just seems like
everything that could go wrong has gone
wrong
so
this year
i experienced the worst pain i've ever
had
in my entire life had natural children
childbirth so like i know how that feels
that hurts and this is
the worst pain i've ever had in my
entire life
um
yeah like so bad that when they would do
wound changes i would literally be
screaming and crying and my nurse who's
known me for three years was crying as
well it was like
it was pretty harsh
and scary
yeah what um
what what like right now
you know i know it's been uh maybe a few
weeks since your last surgery is that co
it's not hot i don't know some weeks or
something yeah so what like right now
what does a day in your life kind of
look like at least you know kind of
broad stroke well right now it's
slightly changed because the doctor said
i could get up and move around but um i
create too much fluid because of all the
debris that was left behind from my bad
hemp implant so for some reason my body
keeps creating fluids so my leg will
swell and swell
and so we've tried wound vacs and other
things right now we have a new guy who
is trying a drain so i have a hole in my
leg and a tube in it and
a thing that collects drain that i have
to pour out every week or every day um
and and it's been mostly in bed honestly
and
you know
the intro it's really kind of stretched
me in a sense of
um you kind of lose your identity when
you're stuck in bed for so long like i'm
used to being mom and wife and
caretaker not the other way around so
i've i've really struggled with
what
if you know i
i'm who am i right now like who am i um
so that's been a really really hard time
for me
but you know but god
god's good yeah yeah but how
like in
oh you kind of alluded to the some of
the hard times like have there i mean
cause you're a woman of well
i know you wouldn't say this i think
she's a woman of great faith um if i
think the fact she has any sort of smile
ever
is pretty remarkable um
but which we'll get to that in a minute
but but
have there been those times of just
despair and just like god has abandoned
me like this just
yeah what's what's that that side of it
been like
i think that faith along with love and
all the other things are things that
grow in us
so i have to say because i've taken care
of a lot of family members who were sick
and dying
my faith solidified pretty strongly
during that time of
i believe god is real i've seen too many
things
he's done too many things for me to
think he's not real i believe god is
real
so i can't say like i ever got to a
point where it was like no you're not
real but there was a lot of why are you
letting this happen to me
but you know i think we often think that
we're supposed to you know have this
cherry life and everything's supposed to
be perfect as a christian and it's not
it's the only difference between me and
my neighbor is that i'm a christian it's
a question of how are you going to
suffer how are you going to make it
through this that that's what makes us
different i think a little bit
and
so
you know my faith has always
been the thing that has kept me grounded
because there are times when i've just
wanted to curl up in a ball and cry and
not deal with anybody yeah yeah talk
share with us a little bit more about
that you use the kind of metaphor of
grounded like what yeah how does faith
play out for you how does how has that
kind of kept you going and kind of
centered in
christ and able to endure
it keeps me going because i know that
there's always hope
i've seen god do amazing things even
miraculous things
so i have to say that it
i just cling to it it's like it's like
the only thing
because even even
roy is the best husband in the world
we've been married 30 years on tuesday
and
he's the best husband in the world but
he makes mistakes just like i make
mistakes so we can't really even 100
percent 100 percent trust
on this
but i can trust on god
that's the one thing i only know i don't
know
anything else i used to think i knew
lots of stuff but i don't know anything
the only thing i know is that god is my
anchor and there's going to be some
really really stormy times there is
going to be times when i can't see the
shore there's going to be times when i
think i'm lost but if you don't get out
there in the storm you won't be able to
appreciate the peace and when time is
good you know um so that's what keeps me
holding on tight i think is that
yeah
well
any um
if folks here are just kind of in a in
their own season of suffering i don't
know would you say anything
to them any input or perspective or
that wasn't one you had asked me it
wasn't um
suffering is okay
it's okay to cry
it's okay to stomp your feet
it's okay
because
jesus did when he was in the garden he
was so overwhelmed he wept and oozed
blood which is a true thing that they
found out can really happen you can be
so overwhelmed that you cry blood
that's overwhelmed
so
to me
it's okay if we cry and if we stomp our
feet and if i don't want to get up today
and if i want to say please
not today
please just give me one day where i
don't have to talk about this is the
only thing i have to talk about you know
please give me something new to talk
about let me not talk about this just
come on please
but i know that he gives me strength and
and this is part of the walk
part of the reason my faith is strong is
because people like your parents and
others shared their faith stories with
me and i was able to hold on to that
when i wasn't sure god was real when i
was kind of like are you real are you
not real
their face stories made me stronger like
when i would hold on to those and go
yeah but
greg tilford said blah blah and so i'm
gonna hold on to that even though i'm
i'm scared and unsure
um
that's that was huge for me to listen to
other people's especially if if you're
new believers or or we're just going
through a period of darkness it's
important for us to share
our stories with each other even the not
good ones
it's we need to because i need that to
help me
so
yeah
your family yeah nikki
we love you you're a great soul like
you're great you'll give her a hand
[Applause]
all right to close out someone grab
these chairs and take them off
um
i want to close this out with uh reading
the verses that we didn't cover
um at least in any depth although i
think as i read you'll be able to to
tell
that we kind of have been talking about
these these verses all night so this is
verse 6 from peter
in all this you greatly rejoice
though now for a little while you have
had to suffer grief in all kinds of
trials these have comes that the proven
genuineness of your faith
of greater worth than gold the gold
which perishes even though refined by
fire so that that faith may result in
praise and glory and honor when jesus
christ is revealed
though you have not seen him you love
him
and even though you do not see him now
you believe in him and are filled with
an inexpressible and glorious joy
for you are receiving the end result of
your faith the salvation of your souls
will you pray with me
lord there is so much
pain in our world
there are
bombings and wars and echoes of wars
there's famine there's children dying
before their time sickness
cancer
surgery after surgery
family separated at borders
unchecked greed
in a belief that it's actually good
god in so many ways it looks like
sometimes your kingdom is not coming
that your will is not being done
and yet it is to that world that you
have called us
to be like children
innocent
faith-filled
present
bringing healing and hope through our
very presence it is to that world that
you have called us to be like teenagers
again energetic hopeful believing it can
be better it is to that world that you
have called us to be like adults wise
matured by suffering
mellow and open-hearted to whatever
comes
knowing that you are with us
and that we
will
conquer because your kingdom will in
fact be established your will is an
inevitability for you are the source of
everything and to you
everything returns
as surely as the sun rises and the ocean
waves recede
help us christ to trust again
give us faith
amen
we're going to close out with this song
it's by a girl named lauren daigle cycle
daigle
but what i love about the message of
this song
is when you
when you've known nikki and you watch
her walk through these years and years
of
procedure after procedure
and
um come out of each one still like
she'll send me and maggie a text and my
response is always like oh my gosh how
could this still be happening and she's
the one saying like
you know but
it's okay god is just giving me enough
faith for today or she's
she's encouraging me
in our text messages
and um what i love is that nikki's story
doesn't say that thing that brett was
talking about it doesn't say
i've had enough faith and everything has
worked out
you know it says things are not working
out and i'm still going to have faith
and that's what i've experienced in my
own story
when
the pain has come and it's been so
overwhelming
and you start to lose track of how to
make sense of this faith thing it's
remembering and seeing the stories
around us like nikki
and and knowing that it's it's not
it's it's it's red what the song is
saying sometimes the prayers don't get
answered the way you want them to and
still yet we can have a hope still yet
we can have faith that god's love is
real and that he is with us in our pain
so
let it speak to you
[Music]
so
letting go of every single dream
i lay each one down at your feet
every moment of my wondering
never
changes what you see
i've tried to win this war i
confess my hands are weary i need your
rest
mighty warrior king of the fights
no matter what i
[Music]
i wish i could walk through when you
don't give the answers as i cry out to
you
i will trust i will trust i will trust
in you
[Music]
truth is
[Applause]
[Music]
i wish i could walk through
when you don't give the answers as i cry
out to you
i will trust i will trust i will trust
in you
i will trust in you
you are my
strength you are my steady
[Music]
there's not a place where
i'm needing you to move
[Music]
as i cry out to you
i will trust i will trust i will trust
[Music]
i will trust in you
well thank you so much for uh for
joining us tonight um
it's been
yeah good good to
be together to worship christ to
re-center before the week and to
remember faith matters so
if you are um new here we would love to
get to know you a little bit better we
have there's a small like the smallest
table you've ever seen
right there through that hallway it has
little cards you just fill it out with
your information and i'll follow up with
you we'd love to just be in touch um
and also we uh i know mariah mentioned
trunk or treat so kind of basically next
week's gonna be really different not a
normal service um it will be the same
time five o'clock
basically we'll be outside we're going
to do like
chili frito pie and
we'll have some like little kind of hot
dog wrap things for kids who don't like
chili and
it'll just be kind of an outdoor
fun time we're going to have some like
games for the kids and then of course
the trunk or treat so um we you know the
more trunks the merrier so if you can
sign up there on that table and
basically it's pretty simple just you
know put a few pumpkins out have the
kids just want the candy right they
don't really care about how fancy your
trunk so don't be intimidated like we
just don't have time to decorate a fancy
just put it without a pumpkin and bring
candy and the kids will love it so
at any rate that'll be from like five to
maybe 6 37 um we'll do that and then you
know you can go to your other halloween
things so it's kind of a unique thing us
meeting in sunday evenings and then
halloween you know it's a little bit of
a strange thing so we'll just make the
best of it should be fun so
um all right
let me send you out with this
benediction
you are god's servants
you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions
and upon you rest the grace of god like
flames of fire
go
love
serve the lord
in the strength of the holy spirit
god be with you all have a great week
[Music]
as i cry out to you
i will trust i will trust in you
i trust in you
i'll trust in you
[Music]
[Applause]
you